there's a photo actually that i really
love that i want to put up on the screen
of collin okay so would high school scar
joe be into high school college um i
don't think so
turns out scarlett johansson doesn't
think a teenage colin jost would have
swept her off her feet which has fans of
the couple all shook this is huge you
know it's just yeah it's crazy it all
went down on wednesday's the drew
barrymore show the talk show host shows
the marvel star this throwback photo of
her now husband which he shared during a
recent weekend update segment on snl
fans of the hit hbo show euphoria have
been harshly criticizing the series
creator for sexualizing the high school
characters plus it's just not accurate i
mean take it from me no one has sex in
high school
yeah so drew asked the burning question
okay so would high school scar joe be
into high school college um i don't
think so
but hey scarlett has some valid reasons
personally that my brother had that same
haircut uh throughout the night both of
my brothers and i just can't
there's no way i mean
when
who decided on that cut as a stylish
thing
what hairdresser was like i'll try this
so yeah wouldn't have been a match back
then but scarlett says timing is
everything we met at snl and it was like
i'd known him
for
a very very long time through that my
first year hosting was his first year
writing the other times that i was there
i was
i was you know in a relationship and i
was not like you're like oh he's cute
but you know right
and um this time the time it was the
timing was right it was like he looked
yeah he i think he
looked differently to me because i was
available like it was just
the timing has to be right it's hard to
have a lot of complaints she's pretty
awesome flash forward to 2022 and the
couple seems happy as ever they got
married in october 2020 and welcomed a
baby boy named cosmo last august and one
thing's for sure scarlett loves
motherhood when eti caught up with the
black widow star in november she gushed
about life with her daughter rose whom
she shares with her ex-husband romaine
doriak and her new baby boy how has it
been with two in the house now opposed
and is rose being a really good big
sister yeah she's seven so she's real
she's very busy uh she's yeah she's kind
of like oh yeah he's cute anyway so all
this happened non-stop talk and um yeah
it's great i'm you know i feel very
fortunate that i've been able to take
this time to really enjoy you know the
early stages of my of my motherhood uh
with our son and it's it's it's been
wonderful i'm in a baby bliss bubble